CHARLES NESSON: Who am I to be doing this enterprise with you?
Why am I doing it?
What's my goal?
Well, I'm the founder of the Berkman Center for Internet and Society
at Harvard, soon to be the Berkman Klein Center, but that's another story.
The Berkman Center goes back to a basic vision of cyberspace
as tripartite in its power structure.
Three huge forces-- the force of states of nations--
the whole idea of traditional law as we've
understood it-- the force of corporate power, market,
extraordinarily powerful economics, and the force of University-- of what you
might think of as ethics, of truth, of the idea that, well, the Socratic idea,
that if we combine our diversity, if we join it and learn from each other,
all we have to teach each other, then we have a force.
And you can see that it's been a force down through the ages.
But here, in its way suddenly, at the advent
of the internet, the idea that suddenly we
are universal in our connection in a way we've never been before,
we find ourselves in a new environment, hostile in many respects,
interesting, intriguing, but altogether a shift from an orientation that
allows us to be individual to one in which we live in a connected space.
I'm a professor of law, law in the sense of process,
law in the sense of Socrates, law in the sense of modes of behavior
that allow us to get along.
And I believe that the number one question posed by internet
is one of governance.
Not the question, how do we govern the internet?
That question, if you understand its dimensions, doesn't have an answer.
But the question rather is how do we recognize that we as individuals
and as institutions, as universities, as states, as corporations,
recognize that we are in a new environment?
And in a new environment, are challenged to learn how to live and thrive in it.
In that environment, the question that we face is, how do we govern ourselves?
And the approach that I would like to follow with you
draws its inspiration from the American jury
and from poker, two of my favorite subjects.
But both with the element in common that people sit around a table,
and they play as equal players in the rhetorical game that goes
back and forth to come to a decision.
So I invite you to come, play rhetorical poker with me,
learn about the original conception of the American jury--
not necessarily where it's come, I'm not teaching you a technical law class--
But the idea of discourse, the idea of listening as a means of persuading.
These are the skills that I would like to see us practice and share.